do you know what i think i think about
all the time
is and i know this sounds weird you know
how easy it must have been
to get away with crimes before cameras
the easiest do you know what i mean like
if you get caught as a criminal
before cameras you're the worst the
worst the [ __ ] worst
criminal because just drive to the next
town man ain't nobody know who the [ __ ]
you are
no idea man there's i did i wrote um
a script me and my friend jonathan check
wrote a script
uh that adam sandler's company bought a
couple years ago
a truce b madison yeah a true story a
guy named rick dempsey who played
he was a catcher for the orioles and the
dodgers
um but he uh told us a story about a
real story about
a um all-star team out in canoga park in
the 60s i think like 1963
something like that and this all-star
team i think
seven of the kids think about this dude
seven of the kids on this one all-star
team went on to play
some level of professional baseball damn
do you know
i mean you know that's to have one is
crazy but this team had rick dempsey it
had robin yount who's in the hall of
fame and had
his brother larry so it has monsters
monsters yeah
the coach on this team you used
the team as cover because it was a
traveling all-star team
to rob a bank in every town he went to
oh wow
and so he he could just go to the field
it wasn't like there was a phone look
out for this dude no
indeed no idea short stops caught
stealing that's what it is
the shortstop's dad was the lead
detective
for the case oh wow so he would come to
the practice
and the coach would ask him and he and
he breaks and he's like no we can't find
these guys
they were the mutton jeff robbers but
because they could
if you were in studio city you could rob
a bank in studio city and just drive to
burbank it's not like they had a picture
no they have nothing you know what i
mean so to get caught as a criminal you
think as a detective
if the away team's playing in cleveland
baltimore yeah you know florida
albuquerque
there's bank robberies and all those the
detectives like
weird my sons i think it was figured out
i think it was mostly california but i
still you know right
this is where we were just playing there
but it was such a crazy story man
have you ever looked i don't mean an
interrupt have you ever looked at uh how
much
bank robbers actually get when they rob
a bank now it's
like three thousand dollars get the [ __ ]
out of it yeah people think it's like
crazy money but
they're only getting away with i think
two to three thousand dollars not worth
it
because i bet you you could get that
much from like a coin shop or a pawn
shop
why are you going to do a bank in 2006
the average bank robbery netted about 4
300. that's
terrible finally an average of 1500 for
all commercial robberies what you should
know before robbing a bank
good thing u.s news wrote that article
the average take out of 7-eleven 760
not worth it what's worth it for you
what's worth
what's worth the risk of going to jail
and possibly getting shot
so you gotta these people are probably
pretty desperate but what's worth it is
it
seven hundred dollars that's not what
rob was seven eleven that's not worth it
it's gonna get you how far no and most
of it's in quarters
like i mean you don't what do you you
don't want that [ __ ] like nightmare
they it seems though like they used to
and i wonder
if they used to get more out of the bank
like
in the movies in the old movies you're
thinking they're like rob won they're
sad
yeah i mean i don't think it's ever been
that way hasn't we just again
movies painted a picture right that
they're they rob one bank they're right
after the sunset right and they
they had a safe full of just cash it's
not that way i would be a terrible bank
robber
i don't think if i was going to commit a
cr like a major crime
i don't think bank robbing is my would
be my
mine would have to be some kind of
feeling like high-end art
no it would be some kind of shyster like
i would be conning people like i think
if i was gonna
commit a crime i would ponzi scheme ah
maybe
or just like you know maybe like a
lonely 65 year old woman
who's just looking for something to hang
out with you're looking for a sugar mama
yeah something might be like then your
name would be like josh the widowmaker
um and then you're just going from like
old cougar
cougar taking money if i was going to i
think that's the only thing i'd be good
at
i'm not a real physically intimidating
dude i see i i think we would do
something like ocean's eleven
like a big one oh yeah dude that'd be
cool but in ocean's eleven
years what role are you in ocean's
eleven like who
i think everyone wants to be george
clooney but i think i'd be more of
don cheadle well no you know what i if
let's let's go more with the italian job
okay i think i'd be
probably most deaf the deaf guy's just
blown [ __ ] up
um i i want to be in the italian job
i'm i'm mark wahlberg you want to be
mark yeah i think so i think so
in ocean's 11 i think brad pitt i like
the fact that he eats in every scene
he's in
i love that part too i don't know that's
right i don't know why but my man gets
to eat in every scene and it's delicious
rick and morty did the do you watch
ricky morty yeah they did a hilarious
uh one of it the heist one where rick
and mort
rick oh my god it's so funny and they
copy ocean's level with the music
yo you son of a [ __ ] i'm man yeah i'm
gonna go home and watch
me my son because he that's his favorite
always eating dude
i wonder why i i don't know but man he
makes me hungry whenever i watch him in
a movie
he is why i might be the old guy that
they go to oh
yeah yeah with the big glasses
yeah dude i can see you rocking the
glasses in the robe i don't want to get
my hands dirty but i'll be behind it
are you if i'm going robe i'm definitely
going to ask scott
i don't i don't like uh robes do you i
don't have one i don't either i know
people who go to hotels and they lounge
in the robe i'm like
i only do have the hotel emma because
they have nice robes it's like
form-fitting it feels nice
but i don't like being all free and like
hanging with my [ __ ] legs now i see
your question
do you think they wash those robes yes
you tell them i do now the hilton
probably not yeah because
i know for sure the reason i don't put
them on is somebody's naked [ __ ]
when they sit down you see i don't mind
it even with covert days i don't give a
[ __ ] i don't
i'm not even talking about covet i just
don't i don't need naked [ __ ] on my
back i'm not too worried about it dude
no when i get off stage at the lab
factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son